i was just talking uh ace about you the
other day you know ace
is how we met originally you know shout
out to ace but um
you know what with what you did with
with the ybn crew
i feel like you got to get a lot of
credit man
you know yeah i feel like uh
first of all just i feel like you know
if we look at like court day like court
day
end up being the next kendrick lamar you
know what i'm saying but
i don't think there's been a crew that's
had like
an impact i want to say like maybe asap
mob
you know like that was like 10 years ago
now you know what i'm saying
i was like 10 years ago yeah when like
yeah when rocky first came out it was
2011 2010 oh
bro tyler the creator [ __ ] um his first
record just turned
uh 10 years old and i was like [ __ ] i'm
getting all this [ __ ] remember later
squad all that [ __ ] what's it learning
squad
his name yeah loiter squad yeah i
remember that
the relationship with everybody right
now it's cool everybody cool
they're just doing their own thing for
real everybody trying to get right with
their young self because
we got a lot of [ __ ] to work on um
cordee right now i think he just
finished this album yeah i
i heard a lot of stuff yeah yeah jay i
saw he just dropped yeah
yeah when it came to court day like kind
of like dropping the name and all that
[ __ ] like was that something like
initially like did you like take any
sort of offense to that when it first
happened or
it really wasn't no offense it was just
like i understand it
but like damn it was just like a damn
feeling but i understood it at the end
of the day because
he did it for him and he did it for the
right you feel me the right purpose he
wouldn't do it for no [ __ ]
right like i understood what he did it
for and at the end of the day when we
knock this [ __ ] out
he's going to be right there solid he's
going to
have our back like how he got his back
ain't going to never be no [ __ ] to where
he's like [ __ ] the [ __ ]
that's hey that's family are you um like
still trying to keep the ybn thing alive
as far as like maybe bringing in new
artists finding new artists all that
yeah it's a lot of people that's in the
background that's going to pop up soon
i've been saying that for so long but
cause it was
what was the other guy there was another
ybn dude who was like funny what was his
name
manny yeah man yeah my cousin where's he
at alabama he just got back from mexico
did you say that like like like like was
he out there for a while no he was out
there for a while like three years he's
like now like he's like god
yeah he was gone he just moved to mexico
nah he had to go oh he got deported he's
not deported but he had to go
i don't know what that means bro he just
had to go close to that though
are you still scouting for talent like
on like grand theft auto and [ __ ]
no i already know everybody for real
like i already got like oh no it don't
really just
i'll be looking for [ __ ] to just pop up
or like it already
it's been there and i just didn't notice
it yet